how do you manage to apply discipline on
yourself rather than just do what you
like you know uh
discipline is really overrated
discipline is just you fighting with
yourself to do something you don't want
to do so I would say it's more important
to find something that you want to do
and that can be productive as opposed to
uh trying to discipline yourself
self-discipline is is uh it's it's tough
you won't sustain it uh like you know
Tiger Woods didn't become a great golfer
through self-discipline what has to be
understood
is that where greatness comes from
it's a very murky Affair it is
non-linear it is unpredictable
perhaps nature in the universe set it up
this way that you have to jump in
and once you jump in the soup
and you're being bombarded through all
sides and you live in confusion and you
have no idea which way is up if the
obsession is there
then what happens is through some messy
process
you find a way you see light at the end
of the tunnel you forge a path through
the jungle when you come out through the
tunnel and someone asks you how you did
it you have no idea the thing that's
almost laughable is when you ask a great
athlete can you show me how you did that
they won't come out and say I have no
idea
they will provide you with some
semblance of an answer which is a
non-answer and what they will do is
because there's a gun point of their
head and their backs against a wall they
will create the highlights when the
human being who watches that follows the
highlights he misses and the reason that
he misses is because it's All the Small
Things I can't watch Roger Federer play
tennis and swing the racket the same way
nor will any description from him on how
to swing the racket get me to swing it
the right way then we go to intellectual
efforts we start asking Warren Buffett
why he invests in the company and there
he can try and create a mental construct
as to how he thinks and how he invests
in the company but there are just as
many details to Warren Buffett's
activities when he decides what to
invest in and how he lives his life and
how he thinks as there are to Roger
Federer's body running around a tennis
court hitting a ball the details are not
transmissible they're not copyable you
can be inspired to try it yourself but
without that sincerity that Obsession
you won't get there
not only are the details not
transmissible the detail is not even
knowable ah so Warren and Roger don't
even know it themselves absolutely not
no great artist knows the things that
you do greatest are the things that you
know not how you do them I would argue
that you're not even there when you do
them you're not consciously thinking
about it I find that when I'm speaking I
do best when I'm not thinking about what
I'm going to say and I don't even hear
what I'm going to say until it comes out
of my mouth
it's like the Bukowski line find what
you love and let it kill you is really
put everything put everything into the
thing you love that that's like the way
to really create special stuff but it's
also the way to yes you have to be
careful given this advice because
they're like they're like bodybuilders
who'll be like just go to the gym be
disciplined I'm disciplined go to gym
but I would argue for those people it's
like it's not even discipline they just
enjoy weightlifting right because there
are people who are jacked but they don't
make much money or run a business right
if they're that disciplined they would
they would be hitting every area of
their life they just really like
business and there's people like me who
just to an extreme level love building
companies right it's not even discipline
for me it's just in my blood it's what I
wake up I don't think about it I don't
push myself I don't need to watch a
motivational video to go work I
just do it it's programmed in me at this
point and I couldn't imagine a world
where I don't wake up and do it every
day
um but I think that a little bit of it
is genetics
um and just how you're hardwired uh not
that it can't be trained or taught and
not that you know and obviously the
friend group you're in influences these
things and over time I think can change
it but someone's just not gonna be able
to flip a switch and then just start
doing a kamikaze approach to building a
business just like like a lot of people
try to flip a switch and start
bodybuilding and quit majority of the
time you know that's uh just not innate
to them but I think a lot of us have the
capacity to do that in some domain yeah
I think if you went about strategically
if you surrounded yourself with fellow
like-minded people and you know slowly
over time switched it uh but if you just
try to like hardcore do it you're just
going to lose your mind
one of the things that we've talked
about before that I always like your
points of view is on strategies for
success there are lots of variables you
need to get right I'm going to list them
and I want your quick opinion on a scale
of one to ten where 10 means oh this is
like a really important thing for
Success right and one is no you don't
even need that okay all right hard work
three or four maybe like early on like
seven or eight at some point but yeah
really three or four in Silicon Valley
that there might be exceptions because
you're playing games winner take all
trying to build the next 50 billion
dollar company where only one can win so
the number one by definition is also
it's gonna hit 10 on everything right
but for General people going through
General Life just trying to be
successful hard work really doesn't
matter that much because we live in an
age of infinite leverage technology
Capital media make it so easy to
multiply your work that what you do and
how well you do it is so much more
important than how hard you do it
we'd like to view the world as linear
which is I'm going to put in eight hours
of work I'm going to get back eight
hours of output right it doesn't work
that way a guy running the corner
grocery store is working just as hard or
harder than you and me how much output
is he getting what you do who you do
with how you do it way more important
than how hard you work right outputs are
non-linear based on the quality of the
work that you put in
but it's true if you're if you're doing
anything creative or trying to pursue
anything that requires like you to be
more successful than a lot of other
people competing to do the same thing
you got to put in the time energy man
yeah and you had to work smarter not
harder I mean some people I I say this
analogy a lot but since we're on the
topic I think for most smaller channels
like if they're pulling a thousand views
of video and they upload a video every
day for 100 days they'll pull 100 000
views but I would recommend you just
think of a really good idea one that
people genuinely want to watch put a lot
of time into the video and you
can pull 100 000 views in a week you
kind of see what I'm saying because I've
most people that I talk to because I
like to counsel small channels sometime
just get in the Motions of just whatever
you know and it's just like if you just
took a step back I haven't even uploaded
the last week I don't care you know it's
not like it's that big of a deal like
and you just make a kick-ass video like
you could like pull exponentially so
many more views you know with so much
less effort you know yeah
the key element of hard work which I
must say is an elephant in the room
which is rarely discussed in the world
is that hard work is considered to be a
door prize it seems to be sort of the
preparing of the bed of failure
um I think that a lot of times hard work
is done in order to have an excuse for
the mind when the Mind comes attacking
and says how come you didn't make it and
if a person is armed with the ammunition
that I have worked hard then he has an
answer for the Mind whereas if he just
sat on the couch and did nothing he
would not have that ammunition so many
times people do hard work in order to
have an answer for the mind because they
know they're going to fail anyways
and externally if I'm an investor in a
company and it fails the entrepreneur
worked hard that feels more forgivable
socially than someone who's just like oh
I tried it I took a shot the market
didn't want it I gave up quickly
when you think of the word say
successful who's the first person or
people who come to mind for you yeah
it's an odd answer because uh you know
most people think of someone as
successful when they win the game and uh
it's whatever game they're playing right
so if you're an athlete you're going to
think of successful uh someone who is a
top athlete and wins that game or if
you're in business then you're gonna
think Elon Musk or uh you know someone
of that sort or in in my mind I would
have answered that question a little
differently a few years ago I would have
said Steve Jobs because he created
something or he was a driving force uh
part of the driving force and the
spearhead for creating something that
has changed the lives for all of
humanity and that's the iPhone uh you
know I think if Mark Andreessen is super
successful not because of his recent
Incarnation as a venture capitalist
which is an interesting one but because
of the incredible work that he did with
Netscape you know he he commercialized
the web browser Satoshi Nakamoto
successful in the sense that he created
bitcoin which is this incredible
technological creation that will have
repercussions for decades to come so in
the classic sense I consider those
creators and commercializers successful
and of course Elon Musk just because he
changed everyone's viewpoint on what is
possible with modern technology
entrepreneurship but that said to me the
real winners are the ones who step out
of the game entirely who don't even play
the game Who rise above it and those are
the people who have such internal mental
and self-control and self-awareness that
they need nothing from anybody else so
there are a couple of these characters
that I know in my life
um some older gentlemen that I like to
kind of learn from and we mentioned our
polish friend earlier I would consider
him successful because he doesn't need
anything from anybody yeah he is at
peace he is at health and whether he
makes more money or less money or with
the next person over from him does
better or worse than him has no effect
on his mental state and bearing uh and
historically I would say that the
legendary Buddha uh or uh krishnamurti
who stuff that I like reading they are
successful quote unquote in the sense
that they step out of the game entirely
uh winning or losing does not matter to
them uh there's some line that I read
somewhere that all of man's troubles
arise uh because he cannot sit in a room
quietly by himself for half an hour
right and if if you could literally just
sit if you could just sit for 30 minutes
and be happy you were successful and I
think that that is a that is a very
powerful place to be but very few of us
get there
you know
um since we have all night arvind I
wanted to tell you the story of this uh
very stressed out investment banker so
there's this guy in New York who's an
investment banker working like 100 120
hours a week totally burnt out you know
just uh flaming out you know just with
this intense and he's of course making a
lot of money but he is uh just
pressed out beyond belief so he uh does
some research and he finds this little
tiny Mexican fishing Village
uh which is in a very remote part of
Mexico where there is a small like you
know one-room Resort
uh and no humans just it'll be just he'd
be the only guest and there's no one
around for Miles he said that's the
place for me so he goes over and he
books himself for a week at that place
to recuperate from New York and
in the morning he gets up and he notices
that there's a heart
uh just off the beach and this guy this
Mexican guy in this Hut have you heard
the story before
no yeah I know all my stories are
original so uh so he sees this Mexican
guy in this Hut and this Mexican guy
pulls out a small boat a small little
canoe and he takes it out in the ocean
and then he's gone for like an hour hour
and a half and he comes back with two
fish
and then he makes a little fire and you
know Cooks one fish and then has that's
his lunch then he goes and takes a nap
and he wakes up in the evening Cooks the
second fish and that's his dinner and
then you know he's just hanging out of
his heart and goes to sleep and then the
next morning the banker notices again in
the morning the guy wakes up takes his
board goes out in the ocean you know
gets the two fish comes back again Cooks
one fish takes the nap second fish and
after three days the banker can't take
it anymore okay so he goes and talks to
the only human he can which is the
Mexican fisherman and so he says that
you know uh when you go out in the ocean
could you catch more than two fish and
uh the Mexican fisherman said yeah the
ocean is full of fish I can catch a lot
more fish so he says uh why don't you
cash catch more than two fish he says I
only need two fish why would I need to
catch more than two fish he says so the
banker says look
if you catch more than two fish then you
would have some extra fish you would
only eat the two fish but you could sell
it in the market you know so the
fisherman says uh and then what he says
well you know then you'd have some money
and you know as you keep getting these
more fish and you get more money uh what
you can do is you can get a second boat
and hire a guy and he's gonna go out in
the boat and fish as well and he's going
to catch a bunch of fish too and now
you'll have more fish because you'll pay
the guy but you'll have some left over
and uh you'll have more to sell in the
market so the fisherman says and then
what he says then you know we're gonna
keep doing this and of course we're
gonna have a fleet which is going to be
bringing this fish but then we're going
to vertically integrate so instead of
selling the fish into the market we're
gonna set up a canning operation and
we're not gonna let those comebacks take
all the margin by doing the canning
themselves we're going to do the canning
and you know we're in this great part of
the country you're going to create a
great brand and we're going to have this
you know organic you know uh fish and
all this stuff and we're gonna can it
and uh we're gonna you know send it out
all over the world so the fisherman says
uh and then what he said and then you
know I'm gonna take you public you know
I'm I'm I'm I'm your man you know I can
take you public I we can do an IPO and
then you know you're gonna have uh lots
of money and uh you know great life and
such and he says and then what he said
then you know when you when you want to
take a vacation you can come here and
hang out and the fisherman just looks at
him that he's already there sorry
exactly I actually do think you told me
that story but it's one of the things I
wanted to share say with the class is
don't be like the banker
be like the fisherman you know so think
of life in terms of the essence of life
there are some basic fundamentals the
first essence of life is the bankers
forgotten is life is finite okay it's
not infinite the second essence of life
is that like my dad used to say we come
to this world naked and we leave this
world naked no one's taken even a pin
with them so basically uh whatever we
get in this world is going to get
recycled back in one way or another so
we don't know how long we are on earth
uh we don't know how we'll leave and so
the best thing you can do is not defer
things into the future but take it into
the present like the fisherman has
reflections
you need a genuine Obsession to succeed
a segment from the book The subtle art
of not giving a by Mark Manson I
wanted the reward and not the struggle I
wanted the result and not the process I
was in love with not the fight but only
the Victory and life doesn't work that
way who you are is defined by what
you're willing to struggle for people
who enjoy the struggles of a gym are the
ones who run triathlons and have cheese
labs and can bench press a small house
people who enjoy long work weeks and the
politics of the corporate ladder are the
ones who fly to the top of it people who
enjoy the stresses and uncertainties of
the starving artist's lifestyle are
ultimately the ones who live it and make
it
hard work is overrated what matters is
good judgment Naval ravikant tweeted in
an age of infinite leverage judgment is
the most important skill let's analyze
these quotes in two parts The Leverage
and the Judgment the infinite leverage
means that your product or service can
be replicated infinitely with the
internet at no marginal cost and you can
get paid by each of these replications
this is why pure hard work is much less
relevant in our current environment
because you don't have to hustle anymore
to make the replications as now you can
delegate this to the robots behind the
internet as Naval also quoted an army of
robots is already here it's very cheaply
available the bottleneck is just
figuring out intelligent and interesting
things to do to them this takes us to
the second part how can we build good
judgment there are two proven ways one
is to iterate fast the more you iterate
the more experience you gain which leads
to better judgment the other one is to
acquire foundational skills and mental
models Navarro vacant tweeted judgment
requires experience but can be built
Faster by learning foundational skills
quote from Charlie Munger you have got
to have models in your head and you have
got to a radio experience both
precarious and direct onto this lattice
work of mental models more about
building judgment on the link above
success is a completely internal metric
quote from nasintaleb contrary
prevailing belief success isn't being on
top of a hierarchy it is standing
outside all hierarchies would you like
to get access to the finest nuggets from
the best books out there if you do you
should check out short form the platform
that I use to learn from books including
my all-time favorite sport Charlie's
Almanac the almanac of navarroikant and
the book series of Nasim taleb for
disclosure short form is not sponsoring
this video but there is an affiliate
Link in the video description I've been
talking about shortphone for a long time
because I love using it and it has
helped me to learn from books in a super
efficient way jorfun takes high quality
books and creates carefully crafted
summaries which contain all the big
ideas from the books the length of the
summaries depend on the amount of
nuggets in the books one thing I really
love about short form is that for any
book summary it connects the ideas with
many high quality online articles and
many times other books that are also on
the short library for instance I read
the summary of the book still like an
artist by Austin Cleon and ideas are
connected to ideas from other books such
as ego is the Enemy by Ryan holiday deep
work by Carl Newbert and Ong writing by
Stephen King all these books are on the
short film library and most of them
makes connections to other books as well
plus the connections to many online
articles so the knowledge grows
exponentially through a natural chain of
ideas I think that learning this way can
help us to build a network of mental
models in a very efficient way and
mental models are very important for
building good judgment if you are
interested in shortfun you can visit my
special link shortforn.com picking
nuggets or use the link in the
description below to get free unlimited
access for 5 days and a 20 discount on
the annual subscription if you choose to
keep going after the end of your trial